okay welcome to Simon's Institute
through our first workshop of the
fairness cluster so I just want to say a
few words about the Simon's Institute
and then I'll pass on the Batum or the
mic to the parent Cynthia
so the silence Institute for those of
you who have not visited here before
which I think it might be the bulk of
you this time is an Institute for
Theoretical Peter science foundations of
computer science with relationship to
other fields and as you could see today
you know sort of computer science and
many others societal issues in law and
we were established in 2012 due to a
very generous gift by the Simons
Foundation and we've been going strong
since we have semester programs with
summer programs where we bring visitors
from all over the world to come and
collaborate together on topics of
specific focus topics we have postdocs
they come every semester so in addition
to being welcome to this workshop could
spread the word this is a place to
really run very sustained studies in
focus areas which are of interest to
computer science especially with
emphasis on theory and foundations and
how they can contribute to the progress
in the world
so in particular we have extremely
fortunate to have a furnace cluster
running this summer so this is another
full-scale program but it's a very
focused program that is dedicated to the
concepts of fairness accountability
transparency but I think the name is
fairness cluster and the the organizers
are Cynthia to work right here in
Sampath who's over there and Jamie
Morgenstern where are you over there
just so you know those are the three
organizers of the whole fairness
clusters this summer and now we have
this very fortunate to have this
workshop organized by Cynthia and Pat
Williams mad law professor who's now a
northeaster and that's her email and
wrong at the root racial bias and
attention between numbers and words in
non-internet data so I just want to say
a few things about logistics which is
really why I'm here I am the director
for one thing and they're very important
too
applause I haven't gotten used to you
know every time I interested I say I'm
in the director and right now I've
gotten used to the word in any case so
the auditorium water is ok but please no
tea or coffee or food and there's
morning and afternoon tea coffee snacks
lunches this time on your own ok
and there's lockers for using lunch time
there's wireless access where you don't
need to have a password or anything Cal
visitor or if you have editor and then
you can use that all talks are live
streamed and archived on our YouTube
channel and actually we have a very
fabulous library of videos on many
topics in computer science and this will
be in addition to it and the
videographer is a made worthy he's
sitting over there behind the booth and
if you have any issues with him hooking
up your computer's speakers and so forth
please talk to him and the event
coordinators are camel and Kevin there's
Kevin around oh he might be outside and
and they're fabulous so thank you for
everything and you can also blame them
for everything no no you can blame me I
don't really care but in any case just
lunge one note is that apparently this
morning there's an article dr. Hsu Adele
talking about this that improves
fairness transparency and accountability
in the challenge of turning old people
into high nutrient slurry and the poor
is an interesting tweet the point being
is that making algorithms truly ethical
is a much greater test and we understood
so far so they are so apparently the
algorithm is fair and transparent and it
abates all these criterias that we would
like to obey but I don't want to be
turned into what is it high nutrient
slurry hey so apparently does not
achieve all set out to achieve and with
that I turn the mic over to our
illustrious leader Cynthia
[Applause]
[Music]
theoretical computer science has
invaluable in articulating and tackling
complex and difficult to define
challenges such as converting the
proposed break propose against cycle of
cryptography to a path of progress and
providing the tools to detect and to
remedy the weaknesses of confidentiality
protection in the US census data in the
modern Information Age reformulating the
tools of auctions and beginning to
harness the power of quantum effects for
computational purposes fairness is very
hard it is contextual it is political it
is intersectional and this very
complexity and the myriad ways in which
algorithms are reaching ever more deeply
into our lives calls out for theoretical
principles for clean definitions and for
meaningful guarantees that interact
constructively rather than deep
destructively now my hopes for this
workshop are twofold first I hope that
it will lead to progress through an
enduring interdisciplinary dialogue that
informs us all about what we are up
against the nature of racial bias in
data features and outcome proxies and
context of use on the one hand and
fundamental mathematical limits of what
we can hope for on the other and I want
that this dialogue will help us to
clarify concrete and realizable
mathematical goals that encourage
fairness in algorithms I also hope that
it will lead to the dissemination of the
concept the idea
of theoretical computer science as a
vehicle to advance social change and
here very much the messenger matters and
I hope that this message coming
specifically from you the participants
will lead to increased participation of
African Americans in theoretical
computer science finally I want to thank
the Simons Foundation the Simons
Institute the sloan foundation for
support of the workshop to Shafie and
stuffy bull Vassar and Peter Bartlett
Kristin cane camel the wall G and above
all the patience and wisdom of my
co-organizer Patricia Williams who has
taught me so much over the past year
[Applause]
Thank You Chevy Thank You Cynthia this
is such a remarkable gathering and I am
humbled and delighted to be here
my concern began or my participation in
this began when Cynthia sort of pulled
me aside while we were still right to
the fellows and said you know race
there's this problem and I said and we
have been it's been the most wonderful
conversation because I've been involved
in some aspect of these kinds of
intersectional ethics of Technology and
law for many years but frequently it
always ends up at the same place which
is this difficulty of discourse and an
complete disagreement about the question
of governance to have the two
disciplines or the broad disciplines of
social science and the the technological
expertise that is gathered here in this
room is extremely satisfying as a
starting point for perhaps a larger
conversation so I think the notion of
fairness and equity grows out of a
completely different set of
philosophical and rhetorical conventions
than the much more libertarian laws
governing markets and many of those who
think about governance in computer
science think about the law of sort of
ultra libertarian market discourse and I
worry that contract and property law
direct ethical and moral considerations
in a very specific direction or order
and a particular market discourse
underwrites a sense of speed urgency
inevitability and foreshortened future
outcome similarly I worry about the
power of corporate interests in shaping
this future corporate foundations far
less than public institutions and so I'm
including in corporate structures
for-profit corporate not-for-profit as
well as for-profit corporations our in
corporations are embodiments of the
singular interests of a narrow range of
Directors and stakeholders or donors and
by their bylaws corporations that
respond
possible to shareholders not publics not
citizens and so coming from my
particular discipline I'm very concerned
that in the history of race those who
are unraised are generally described or
governed by constitutional law and
discourse and those who are marked as
race are generally governed by the law
of contracts and property that they are
within a particular set of discourse
outcomes and as and so for me the
problem of race is broader than simply
black and white it is this phenomenon of
suddenly as a chef he talked about you
know the elderly becoming slurry for
purposes of a product and that product
vocabulary the vocabulary of of that
kind of market outcome is a racial
discourse even if it's not in the
context of what we usually think of as
race so race isn't just about black or
white it's not just a problem of
carelessly reductive taxonomy it's also
an unexamined ritual of naming as owning
and owning frequently implies the hubris
of assuming we know exactly how
something works and it's far too easy
thing to think that we know what race
does and I hope that our discussions
here will be marked by a kind of
humility that marks a recognition that
we have departed from the realm of the
familiar I think it would serve well if
we should who bring a sense of the
unfamiliar to the infinitely
combinatorial were wonders of
algorithmic
and genetic cartography my worry is that
we seem to be following to learn script
of near ancestors we colonize and plant
flags and plot geographies and build
fences in the name of patents we claim
authorship of DNA tests we pretend to
own algorithms as disconnected info bets
infobits whose formations are the same
as the book of life or some kind of deus
ex machina or susceptible of flat
translation into words sentences and
speech and I worried that that's a
blindness precisely to the complexity as
well as to the simplicity of our new
technologies it is a blindness to to the
richness of spoken language not just
numerical representation being spoken
language is magical in its ability to
teach us through the use of
for but it too is reductive it works
only so far as we are dealing with
concepts that can be analyzed analyzed
because known and when we are mapping
the unfamiliar we would do well to
hesitate before tagging new phenomena
with the closest familiar handle and
races but one such property assertion
it's a fantasy and imaginative
construction just as family names
signify associations allegiances
marriages borders to be asserted but not
necessarily biology so two religions
ethnicities nationalities and metaphors
with baggage history and extra
expectations and data doesn't always
grasp the defining power and richness of
metaphor as an effective human
organizing dimension and so that brings
me back to the question of more broadly
disabling narratives and the dignitary
interests at stake and the potential
irreversibility of both the human
experimentation and the quasi
governmental functions of algorithmic
assortment this question of dignitary
regard is endlessly complex territory
but I think to even begin to negotiate
it we might want to align the problem
with the social practices of racing and
disabling and I don't mean to say that
race is a disability but how we label
create hierarchy hierarchy and whether
we consider muted bodies the stateless
non-human life or even what I heard one
person at a conference recently called
crackpots as part of the public whose
voices must be taken into consideration
before acting that is a process of
racing and and it's why I again I think
of race the process of racing is not
something which is just about black or
white
so the ethics of using bodies as fields
for experimentation is not a simple one
we are avoiding the hard questions of
whether we should be treating an
indisputably non-consenting body or
series of bodies as though it were
non-existent or a thing or as though
these bodies and I mean ultimately we're
going to be talking about human and
non-human bodies
as though it were in mine from which
future but not present values maybe mind
and that question of extracting future
value is again the language of Commerce
in a way that is very oppositional to
the question of constitutional concern
whether or not we want to place that as
the United States Senate or whether or
not we want to talk about how
corporations themselves are configured I
look forward to
[Applause]